Now the course,
just to summarize again,
the course is the standard financial
theory course that was made popular over
the last 10 years and a bunch of
business schools where they and,
and those guys who develop this material
basically thought that markets were
great and it was,
finance was almost a separate part,
could be walled off from much
of economics. So here at yeah,
we've never taught finance that way.
We've always taught it as
a part of economics and the
crisis reasonably I think
has made it clear that that's probably
the way one should really think about the
problem. So it's become very
fashionable now to say that, you know,
financial theorists had everything all
wrong and to ask how it is that they got
everything all wrong,
why didn't they anticipate the crash?
And this two standard critiques of a
standard financial economics are a,
it didn't allow for, um, psychology.
And you'll hear about that from
Schiller next semester. And B,
it didn't take into account collateral
and it was all done in a very special
case. A, a knife edge
case. And that's what,
and that if you looked at it a little bit
more broadly, you would see you would,
you would reach,
you would realize that the kind of
crisis we've had now is not such an
unfathomable we'll thing. In fact,
it's happened many times before.
So that's the perspective I'm
going to take in this class.
So to put it a different way, Krugman,
very recently in the New York Times,
you may have read his magazine
article, uh, road exactly that,
that there are two problems maybe that,
you know,
that financial theory has failed us.
Why has it failed as well?
Because it didn't have psychology
and it didn't have collateral. And,
uh,
he didn't talk much about the collateral,
which is obviously something that he's
not thought very much about before.
But together with the collateral,
he sort of said, you know, it's uh,
too much. Uh, how did he put it? He said,
too much seduction by mathematics.
The,
the financial economists were seduced
by their own mathematics into believing
stuff that a sensible person who didn't
pay enough to pay so much attention to
mathematics wouldn't do well.
Although the critique in this course is
going to be partly based on collateral,
the rest of recruitment said,
I completely disagree with.
I regard that as a kind of
Taliban approach to economics.
You know the more technology
and fire power you use,
the more you're going to be misled.
That's what the Taliban believe and they
want to get rid of modern technology
and you know,
return to first principles.
So I think in fact the problem with modern
finance was not too much mathematics
but too little mathematics.
And they made these very
special simplifying assumptions
and didn't realize how
important the assumptions were to
the conclusions. So we're going to,
we examine all that and that's
what we're starting at now.
We're going to consider, first of all
the argument that free markets work best.
So we started with a little example, a
Oh by the way, the first problem set,
if I didn't mention it,
is due Tuesday.
So you need to bring it
to class and we'll have,
and you're going to turn it into each of,
there'll be a box with each of
your section leaders names on it.
So supposedly you're been able to sign
up for sections by now, is that right?
Anyway, it's on the web. So you pick a
section and sign up for it. And you know,
if you wait too long,
you're sectional fill up the time.
So there are eight sections. You ought
to be able to find one of them that,
that fits your schedule and you need
to turn it on on Tuesday in class.
By the end of class. You know, maybe you
can scribble something during the class,
but by the end of the class we're
going to take the problem sets.
And after that it's too late
to hand them in. So you know,
all of you are going to have problems.
You're going to have, you know, midnight,
a session,
all nights,
things they're going to have to do
to for some other course, you know,
grandmothers are going to die. All
sorts of things are gonna happen. Uh,
but we don't take the problem sets late.
So you ha there'll be 10 problem sets
and we're only going to count nine of the
grades, so you'll have one
free pass. And, um, you know,
that's what life is and it's just too
complicated to keep track of people
handing them late all the time.
The answers are going to go on
the web right after the class.
And so it's just in the past,
you know,
we negotiated with every person who
was late and it's just too complicated.
And when you make a simple rule, you
know, grandmothers don't die anymore.
So anyway, that's how we're
going to a work at in the class.
You just have to turn it in and you know,
if there are 10 of them,
only nine count.
If you miss one all together,
it's really not going to change your
grade anyway. If you miss half of them,
that's going to have some
effect on your grade.
And so I don't encourage you to do that,
but I'm sure you won't do that. Okay.
So I think that's all the
preliminaries are two midterms,
one in the middle of the class
and one right at the end. Anyway,
the question we want to spend the whole
of the class on today is whether the
free market is really such a great idea.
And the,
the quintessential example in which it
is a great idea is the one we did in
class on the very first day we had a
bunch of football tickets and there were
buyers, each of whom knew his
own valuation and sellers,
each of whom knew her own valuation.
And we threw everybody together and
just very briefly explained the rules.
By the way,
the only important rule was there were
two important rules you had to announce
publicly and loudly what price you
are offering. That's very important.
You don't have any secret deals
that would've screwed everything up.
And secondly, we had a rule about once
you make a deal, what happens? You know,
how does the thing actually get
transferred? And you know, so there was a,
one of the ta stood by and wrote it
down and the two people exchange the
footballs and you know, agreed to
it and walked off stage. So this,
the actual mechanics of the
transaction, uh, you know,
to make sure that the person turning
over the money actually gets the football
ticket.
That of course it's incredibly important.
And that's the thing that gets
left out often in finance.
That's the collateral business
that we're going to come to later.
How do you know that the guys actually
going to pay you? What he promises? Well,
he's got to put up collateral and so
that you can trust him. So we're gonna.
So without that there would
have been a big problem.
And what we're going to come talk about
that in the old days when you bought a
stock, someone on a bicycle would
carry the certificate, you know,
from one place,
you know,
someone would carry the check from one
guy to another guy and the person then,
then the bicyclist would
get off as you know,
we'd get the stock certificates and, and
ride the bike back to the, to the buyer.
So it was a, you know, if one broker
to another broker and the Co, you know,
sometimes it took a couple of hours.
So there was a spacing in between when
the guy gave over the money and when the
guy got the stock back and uh, you
know, you have to allow for that.
Maybe we'd take a couple of days
to process on everybody's books.
So there's a thing called x dividend.
When you buy a stock,
you know the old buyer continues to
get the dividends for awhile until the,
the old owner until a particular date
after which the new buyer starts getting
the dividends,
if there are any.
And everybody has to understand that
cause after you allow for the, the, the,
the actual trading technology. So all
those things are going to come up later.
And they were in the
background of this example,
but nevermind that the point
now is that these people,
everybody just knew their own valuation,
not anybody else's valuation and
chaos ensued, hardly any rules.
And miraculously, almost instantly
with less than two minutes,
they figured out what to do
and they manage to get the
football tickets into the
hands of the people who
liked them the most.
And I'm going to just say that
slightly more mathematically.
You could model what everybody did
as having a utility function, uh,
for football tickets.
Okay. So the top person,
Mr 44 gets utility of 44 for having
one ticket and tickets beyond that.
Don't give him extra any utility,
just you still utility 44 similarly,
ms six there at the bottom,
she had utility six for a football ticket,
but there's also money in the background.
So the the welfare function depended on
the football tickets and money and was
you ax plus m.
So why does that capture what went on?
Because Mr 44 knowing that the football
tickets worth 44 he would say to
himself, should I get a ticket
or not get a ticket? Well,
if the price is under 40 for the amount
of money he gives up and loses is going
to be less than the amount of utility
gains for the football tickets.
So therefore he'll buy the ticket.
So this utility function,
you x plus m captures,
the idea is, you know,
represents the goals of the
people involved in the experiment.
Each of them has a different view of x,
but all of them are the form Ux plus m.
And so the conclusion was of the
experiment and of the theory supply equals
demand.
The conclusion is that the
football tickets are going
to end up in the hands of
the people who like them the best.
So what does that mean?
That means that enact Librium
inaccurate Librium uh,
uh,
the final allocation
allocation
maximizes
total welfare.
Okay. Now what does
that mean? Well, if you,
each person I has a different
utility function. Okay?
And so if you add up over all the people,
ah,
you get the total welfare
of every single person,
they economies total welfare and it's,
I'm now about to prove,
but it should be obvious that total
welfare is maximized at that equilibrium
that you actually found in class almost.
It was just one tiny,
tiny deviation from the
theory. Nobody made a mistake
by the way, you know, but I,
I think I mentioned this many times,
I've done this experiment before and
you know, Mr uh, let's say Miss 30,
well we'll say Mr 20 in Mr 12 gets so
upset that he can't buy any ticket and
he's standing there, you know, with,
you know, you know, embarrassed.
Then everyone else has traded and he's
still sitting there with his original
football ticket. He ends up bidding 30
or something to get a football ticket.
Okay. Nobody made a mistake
this time. And so it, it,
it happened almost as
the theory predicted.
So let's just think of the theoretical
outcome in the theoretical outcome where
the price is 25 and those
topic people have it,
that final allocation maximizes
total welfare. Why is that? Well,
whatever the money distribution was,
you couldn't change total welfare because
if I give up some of his money to her,
to Jay, the total amount of
money, it's still the same.
And if you add up the
welfares of all the people,
you're just going to get the total
of amount of money on the right.
And it won't make any difference.
So therefore to maximize welfare,
all you have to do is
maximize the sum of you have.
You have to put the football tickets in
the hands of the people who want them
the most. That's going to maximize
welfare because, um, that maximizes the,
some of the Ui of exes and
rearranging the MS doesn't matter.
So we found an equilibrium that
echo Librium maximize total welfare.
So that was the original argument for
why equilibrium was such a great idea.
The greatest good to the greatest
number became mathematical.
It maximizes the sum of welfare. So the
sum of utilities, they called it, okay?
That was the utilitarian,
utilitarian view of economics.
Utilitarian view.
Okay. And that's sort of the
view that was prevailed in 1871.
All right. Now they made one
generalization from that we found before,
which is that if you think of
not eight different buyers,
but one buyer or maybe two
different buyers, you know,
who's where the utility functions are,
this concave function.
So their Ui of x plus m where you evacs
Ui of one could be 44 and UI of two
could be 44 plus 40,
which is 84.
That consolidated person
would behave exactly like, uh,
the individual. He buys as many
tickets as they would collectively. Um,
and so nothing would change.
The football tickets will,
would still end up in the hands of
the people. One of them the most,
maybe it would be one guy who held
three tickets instead of three different
people,
but the tickets would still be in the
hands of the highest valuation holders.
And so you would get
exactly the same conclusion.
One last lesson from that example
is that the price turned out to be,
have nothing to do with the
total value or football tickets.
The price turned out to be equal,
more or less to what the marginal buyer
in the marginal seller thought it was
worth. So Mr 26th, and Mr and Miss 24,
they're the ones who control the price.
What 44 thought was totally irrelevant.
So that was why it was called the
marginal revolution in economics.
So Adam Smith who was so
puzzled because he said,
water is so valuable and has such a
low price and diamonds are so useless.
Really, when it comes down to it
and they have such a high price,
the answer to his puzzle is simply yes.
Water at the beginning. And you know,
Ms 44 will be 44,000, whereas if
we had a same model for diamonds,
uh, sorry, um,
diamonds would also be
very big at the beginning,
but the point is there's so much water
in the economy that the marginal value of
an extra gallon of water is not very high.
Um,
the marginal value of water is low,
even though the total value,
which is the area under the
demand curve is very high. Okay?
So that's the lesson that we
learned, um, in the first class.
And now we want to generalize
this to a much, um,
more sophisticated model and one but one
you can still compute very easily and
we're going to see how these special
assumptions don't quite work so well. Uh,
okay. So, yes. Sorry. Please. Yeah,
please interrupt me at
anytime with questions. Yes.
Can you explain again?
Yes.
Okay. Um, so her question
is, I said very quickly,
which you'll see later.
I pressed the button too soon.
If I press down and it's halfway up,
does that just break the
whole thing or anyway,
okay.
So her question is I she wants,
she would like to know
again why it is that uh,
I can sort of combine people
into one person and what didn't,
what do I mean by that? So what I
meant by that is if I have two people,
Mr 44 and Mr 40, I'm taking the buyers
to be, he's and the sellers to be hers.
I have to two guys,
44 and 40 and I said any price,
if the price is above 44,
neither of them will want to buy.
If it's between 44 and 40, just mister
40, we'll buy in. If it's below 40,
both of them will buy now.
Suppose instead.
But each of those guys
is only in one ticket.
Mr 40 Ford Utility as Ui Ui of one is 44,
Ui of two was still 44, he doesn't
get anything out of a second ticket.
Suppose now I had a third person, uh, uh,
a bigger person whose utility,
you know,
k of one is 44 and UK
if two is 84 44 plus 40.
So that person now is a, is a bigger
guy. Uh, he's interested in more tickets.
That's what I mean by bigger,
he's going to behave himself
exactly the same way.
The other two separate
people behaved collectively.
So if the price is above 44,
he won't buy either ticket
because if it's above,
if it's 50 and he buys one ticket,
he'll have lost 50 and
he'll have gain 44 noodles.
So he will have been worse off than when
he started and he certainly won't buy
to be even worse off. If the price is
between 44 and 40, he'll say to himself,
this is the marginal revolution.
If I buy the first ticket,
I pay a 42 and I get 44 out of it.
So I've gained two you dials.
But now if I think about buying
a second ticket for 44, 42,
and I only get 40 out of it,
I'm going to start losing.
So I'll stop with one ticket.
So that guy will behave
exactly the same way.
The two people separately behave.
So whether it's two guys
separately or one guy together,
it doesn't make any difference there.
Total actions. Exactly the same.
And in the end,
the football tickets have ended in the
hands of the people liked them the most.
Maybe I need a lot of more water than you
do. Um, but it felt, you know, but if,
if I need it much more than you do,
then all those gallons, you know,
the first few, maybe the first 20 gallons
I drank, I needed more than, than uh,
you know, your first gallon.
And after that, you know,
you started needing water
as much as I did. Something
like that. So the, the, the,
the tickets or the water ends up in
the hands of whoever needs it most.
And it may be that they're more than
one unit in each person's hands. Okay.
Any other questions before
I raise the thing again?
All right, now I want to join. So
that sounds all very convincing,
but it's not going to turn
out to be quite so convincing.
So let's try and generalize this
model to a more sophisticated thing.
And so I'm following an example which is
in the notes. So you'll find that most,
you know, if you read the notes, um,
you know, oh, so the textbooks,
because the approach I take, you know,
and that we take it, Yale is quite
different from the standard approach.
You're not going to be
able to follow a textbook.
That's why I give you a whole list of
textbooks. I encourage you to read them.
They're great books. They're
famous people. I, there are,
most of them are quite good friends
of mine, so I endorse them all,
but they're differently
presented than this course.
And that's why you need to rely on
the, on the notes a little bit. Okay?
So let's just take this, uh, example of,
um, the first example. Suppose
now that we have two gods,
but they're
going to be continuous. The, you know,
you don't have to have just one
football ticket or two football tickets.
We have two goods which are going to
call x and Y and we've got two agents,
a and B. And so WIA of x, f of x and y.
That's the welfare function like we
had before. Okay. Is going to be,
um,
whatever.
I had a hundred x minus one half x
squared plus Y and I'll s and now Viet v
endowments of chords,
which I was a little bit
fast and loose about before he a of x,
e a of why all cough.
That's the endowment of a,
okay,
how much he has to begin with the
facts and why I say it's four and 5,000
okay. And then let's make
it another person. Wb
is welfare function or let's say his and
her welfare function is 30 x minus one
half x squared plus y and her endowment,
e B,
a,
B of x and Eby of why
equals
80 and 1000.
Okay?
So this is supposed to be shorthand for
an economy in which there are thousands
of people, millions of people, every
person characterized by the utility.
They get the goals they have over the
consumption goods and they're starting
endowments and they're all going to be
thrown together and expect it to trade.
Another example, we can do one more
exam. Another example. Let's say
don't work out both of these,
the same kind of examples you're going to
do on the problem set. Another example,
sorry,
I can't remember my examples.
I won't meet to look at these
after I write the examples down.
Okay.
Okay, so another one is WC of x.
Y equals three quarters
log x plus one quarter log y
and he see the endowment of c
equals two and one.
And meanwhile I have another person d
of x and Y it's endowment is two thirds
log x plus one third log
y and her and downwind.
Yeah,
one, two. Okay. And of course I could have
had an economy in which they
were all there at the same time,
but I'm going to just keep
them to do two examples.
So you see the economy
consists of many people,
many goods may be many people and uh,
each with different endowments
and different utilities.
And if you throw them all together,
what's going to happen? Okay?
And so we have a theory now, a theory of
equilibrium that explains what happens.
And we can use that.
A few tricks,
which I'm going to teach you now to
actually solve concretely for what's going
to happen in each of these cases. It's
very simple. And of course we haven't.
And the next step is going to be to add
finance to it and financial variables.
But in the, at the bottom, we still
want to have economic variables.
See here we've got the consumption of
two different codes, x and Y, okay?
And we want to see what's
going to happen. All right? So
aqua Librium is always defined
by turning things into equations.
So we said the equations
here are going to be that.
So what is a going to do?
Well,
the indulgent has variables.
VN dodginess variables
are going to be Px,
p y,
x, a, x, y, a.
Okay.
XB. And why me? That's what
everybody has to decide in the end.
A has to decide the prices
have to emerge for x and y.
We're assuming again that these people
by the one I have one agent a and one
agent B, I really mean there's
a million agents, just like a,
an a million agents just like be,
and they're all shouting and screaming
at each other and they're in some kind of
market.
So if there's only one agent of each type,
there'd be bargaining and
threats and be very complicated.
But with lots of people of each type,
that's what I'm talking about.
So when our football player example,
there were football ticket example,
there were 16 people competing with each
other and you don't really need much
more than three or four or five on a side,
um,
at least for to get,
you know, competition.
So with enough competition,
the theory says the prices are going to
emerge and people are going to look at
the prices and decide how
much they want to buy,
what do they want to end up consuming?
So a has to make his decisions and
bs to make her decisions. And, uh,
so those are the indogenous variables.
The exogenous variables were all of the,
you know, 80 1,001 half, you know,
one times y a hundred times x.
All those numbers are,
are exogenous. The utility functions,
the endowments are exogenous.
So these are all the exogenous things.
So the theory is going to say,
how do you go from exogenous to endogenous
and it's going to be just a bunch of
equations. So what, what
are they each wanted to do?
So a is going to maximize
Wia evacs
and why such that as we said,
the critical insight,
the budget constraint was p why of why
less than or equal to m p x times e a x
plus p y times e a why?
But we know what these numbers are.
Ea x is um,
four and he a why is 5,000
so a takes it for granted.
Theory says it's, it's
very shocking, but it's a,
takes it for granted that she could be,
that he can sell all of his
endowment if he wanted to,
four units of x and 5,000 units of y and
get the money from doing that and use
the money to spend on his final
consumption's. Let's go this x say,
and why on his final
consumptions of a x of x say and,
and why Aa.
So let's call this,
let's leave out the A's here for a minute
because those are the choices he has.
He wants to Max over x and y.
So there are many possibilities.
It has to satisfy this budget constraint.
And similarly,
why is going to be maximizing,
uh,
over x and y WB of x, y. Okay.
Such that x, x plus p. Why,
why less than or equal to g x
times 80 was p y times a thousand.
I think I remember the
numbers finally. Okay, so,
and now what we want to do is we want to
solve for these variables so that when
a taking px and pys given maximizes
his utility function, he'll choose x.
Say an XP and B,
we'll choose y a and why be
such that demand? Equal supply.
Okay. And so I'm going to write, um,
over here, maybe demand equal
supply. So we know that in the end,
so the choices,
so whatever these choices are,
they're going to lead to him choosing x.
Say and why a and her
choosing xb and why B.
And it's gotta be that x plus x,
B equals e a x plus e a B,
which equals four plus 80 equals
84 and it's gotta be that.
Why a plus.
Why B has to equal e a y plus.
Eby. Sorry, bad,
which equals
5,000 was 1000,
which equals 6,000.
Okay, I hope I remembered everything. So
all right, so those are of the
equation suppliers to equal demand.
And what are the,
and now let's just do a little trick here
to get some of the other equations. A,
he's going to spend all his money.
What's the point in not spending money?
Because the more x he has and
the more why he has really more,
why has the better off he is,
he's not going to waste money.
So this is going to turn
out to be an equality here.
Okay?
Okay. So that's actually an
equation, not just the a variable.
So p x times x a,
now the actual solution plus um,
p y times y a has to
equal x times four plus p.
Why Times 5,000? That's,
that's an equation.
And then similarly,
why she's not going to waste her money.
She's going to spend it
all if she's optimizing. So
this'll turn into inequality.
And so this'll give p y p x times x,
B Plus p y times y B equals px
times 80 plus p y tons of thousand.
So we've got four equations and now
we have to do the marginal equation.
Crucial marginally equation.
So what does that say?
That says one eight. Okay, we
talked about this last time.
You've all seen it before.
So I can go quickly.
But this was the critical insight
that took years to develop marks.
Couldn't figure it out
until his dying day.
He was trying to understand what these
marginal guys were doing. And so you know,
so the idea is that the margin you to,
if you've optimized by choosing x a Xb,
if he's optimized choosing x Ane Xb, it
has to be that the last dollar he spent,
he was indifferent
between where he spent it.
Otherwise he would've moved at all
or from one thing to the other thing.
So it has to be that the margin utility
of X.
Okay.
At x a n y a divided by the price of x.
So what is that?
What's the margin utility of x?
It's a hundred minus.
That's a derivative of acts.
A hundred minus two times a half,
100 minus X.
Okay.
Has to equal the margin
utility to a of why
divide by, sorry, I just meant to,
we've warmed here
equals the marginal utility of a,
a of why evaluated at Wa x a
n y a. Okay. Divided by the price of y.
So that equals one.
Okay.
Margin utility of why is just
one the drove of why is one
okay. And then we have to
write the same thing for B,
the margin utility out of y of x,
B of a f, x for X. B.
And why be lied by the price of x.
So what is it for me?
It's 30 minus x
divided by Px.
Not very good.
Board management,
uh,
has deep wall and this is also going
to turn out to be one over p y equals
march.
Utility of B of y X.
Say X. B y B divided by p. Y.
Okay, so those are the equations.
Now is that make sense to everybody?
I think I need to pause for [inaudible].
I'm going to do exactly the same
thing with that other system,
but let's just see if we can
figure this out. Okay. That,
um,
you always right.
So equilibrium is this
very involved thing.
What everybody does depends on what
everybody else is going to do because how
much did you pay for something?
Depends on how much you think you can
get it by offering it to some other guy.
You know, if there are million
A's and a million bees,
you're dealing with one of the bees,
maybe the other be,
we'll give you a better deal.
So you have to think about what the
other people were doing before you can
decide what to do yourself. All that
is captured by the idea of the prices.
Somehow people get into their minds what
the best deal they can get is that's
the prices px and p y.
Given those prices a,
each agent looks at his budget set or
her budget set and decides what to do and
what should they do? They should,
um, equate margin utilities.
That's the key insight.
The margin utility per dollar of x has
to equal the margin utility per dollar of
why that just says that the budget set
is tangent to the indifference curve.
Okay?
That's what that says.
So you take the ratio of margin utilities
and equals the ratio of prices and
cross multiplying. It says the margin
utility per dollar. You know this,
this, the slope of the indifference
curve is margin utility,
let's say of a x of a
margin activity of y.
And the slope of the
budget set is px over p y.
So if I just put the px down here in the
margin utility up there that just says
the margin chili of x divided by px equals
the marginal utility of y divided by
p y.
That's something that you could
waste a huge amount of time on.
I don't have to do it because I know
that you all have seen it before and the
one guy who hasn't seen it
before, um, is, you know,
going to figure it out himself. So, so,
okay. The Dean would've been, so we
have a tremendous advantage here.
I can just skip over that immediately
and make use of that fact. Okay.
So that's the critical insight.
You've taken this incredibly complicated
system and reduced it to a bunch of
equations,
which you can put on a computer,
which is about what I'm about to do and
solve it with the flick of a button.
Okay. And, um, so are
there any questions here?
Let me pause again with how I got it.
Got these equations.
Okay. So it's a little bit complicated,
but of course, once you've understood it,
it's not so complicated.
It reminds me a little bit now who
first thought of all this stuff.
The amazing thing is, incidentally,
these equations always have a solution.
You know, she had take, take typical
equations in any field, you know, physics,
mathematics, you know, just
random equations. You know,
they're not going to be solvable. I
mean, x squared plus one equals zero.
That's just one equation.
It doesn't have a solution.
And if you have simultaneous equations,
why should there be a solution?
The economic system always has a solution.
This was an astonishing
fact. First approved, uh,
by air all my thesis advisor,
the brew who did it at Yale
as an assistant professor
and didn't get tenure and
later won the Nobel prize. And, uh, this
happened several times at Yale, Arrow,
Debreu and um,
and Mckinsey
all separately of at least two guys
ended up writing a joint paper anyway.
Um, they found that this system
always, always has a solution.
There's something special
about the economic system
that has a solution that has
to do with diminishing marginal utility,
which are not going to
talk about in this class.
But it's quite a fascinating thing.
And they base their argument on
an argument that Nash had given,
uh, for games. And this whole thing
is very related to nash equilibrium.
And I'm sure you've heard of Nash and
many of you have maybe seen the movie a
beautiful mind. Well, about five
years ago, shortly, you know,
a couple of years after
the movie came out, um,
Nash is still very much
alive and ever so slightly,
not quite as wacky as it used to be.
And so the Indian gain
theory society opened.
It was founded, believe it
or not, just five years ago,
despite all the brilliant
Indian economists,
the Game Theory Society was
founded about five years ago.
And they had an opening conference
where six people gave talks,
including Nash. So I was one of the
people who gave a talk. And, um,
there were thousands of people who
showed up mostly because of the movie.
And there's, I mean, there's just
thousands and thousands of people.
So afterwards we went on
tour to, uh, you know,
traveling to a bunch of different
cities and every city we went to,
we get off the, the, uh, you
know, the, the, the train or
the limousine or something.
It'd be a throng of people
there waiting to meet Nash.
And there'd always be a press conference.
And after the press conference there'd
be a picture on the front page of
whatever city, you know, and these
were all great cities, news, you know,
city we'd gone to and always there was
nash and everybody else was cropped out
of the picture. But anyway, in
one of these first conferences,
I'm just illustrating, um, Nash
equilibrium here. Somebody said,
some reporters says, we've
seen the movie, you know,
but can you really tell us in a word,
what is Nash Equilibrium?
Competitive Equilibrium, what does
that, we're just seeing a word,
what does it mean? What does
it mean for us? And so each
of us took a try and trying to explain,
uh,
what Nash equilibrium was
including Nash, the, the, the,
they didn't go too well,
the explanations until they got to Alman.
He was also one of the people who spoke
and he subsequently won the Nobel Prize.
Um, and, but anyway, at the time he hadn't
won it yet and he was, he's Israeli.
He's also a great figure.
And so Almand says, ah,
that question reminds me I
can't do his Israeli accent.
That question reminds me of the
first press conference cruise. Jeff,
who you might remember was
premier of the Soviet Union.
This was in the time of Kennedy and
thumping the table and the Cold War and
stuff.
The first press conference Khrushchev
gave to Western reporters and somebody
said,
can you tell me in a word,
describe in a word the health of the
Russian economy? And Khrushchev says,
good. And then the reporter says,
I didn't really mean one word,
take two words and tell us what is
the health of the Russian economy.
And Khrushchev says, not good. So,
so,
so almond says in Echo,
Librium in one word is
interaction in two words,
rational interaction.
So anyway, that was his,
and so his definition managed to get
into the newspapers and none of ours did,
but so that pretty much summarizes it.
It's interaction but rational interaction.
So,
and it's captured by the idea that
everybody anticipates the price and those
prices are going to really
lead to the markets clearing.
So they all are anticipating the right
prices and behaving as optimally as they
can and choosing the best thing
in their budget sets. Okay. So
I, I, um, put this on a
computer and solved it,
which we're going to do in a second, but
there's a trick to solving this by hand.
Okay? And so I might as well just do the
tricks by hand because on an exam for
example, I'm not going to be able
to give, you're not going to,
you're going to use the computer.
It's very simple.
You'll see in one minute you can
solve this on a computer. But uh,
by hand it's a,
it's worth knowing how to do.
And you probably know how to do
this. So, but let me describe it.
So what you do is you say,
um,
let's just look at the,
okay,
so the first thing to observe is that the
prices don't really matter up to scale
or multiples vol. Ross, by the way,
it was the first made this argument.
So while Ross was, one
of them are, you know,
one of the marginalist
in 1871 from Roseanne.
So he says, look, doubling the
price isn't going to do anything.
It's just like changing
dollars into sense.
If you look at everybody's budget set
and you double px and he why you're
doubling both sides of the equation,
you're not doing anything.
So if px and p y or part of an equilibrium
to px and two p y will also be part
of the equilibrium because the price is
only appear here in the budget set and
doubling them all,
it doesn't do anything.
So really you might as well
assume that px equals one.
Okay?
Okay. So he says, well that
gets rid of one variable.
You know you've got six variables
and six equations, you know,
so you can all solve them. But there's
so many, it seems too complicated.
But now you've got rid of one equation,
one variable.
We can also get rid of one equation.
He says,
so how can you get rid of one equation?
Well suppose we clear the x market,
we found x say and what we find x say x,
B y a am y B and the two and Px and p y
and all the equations are satisfied one
through five but we, all these
equations are satisfied. Um,
one three, four, five and
six were all satisfied.
We haven't checked equation too though,
whether that market is going to clear and
Varo said, well it has to clear. Okay,
the last equation, the last, uh,
market, we don't need to worry about.
Why is that?
Because
if x say plus x B equals ea plus Eeb,
that means collectively all the
agents are spending on good acts.
Exactly all the money that they're
collected. We getting by selling good ex.
Okay.
That's what the top equation says.
Cause you knew multiply
through the whole thing by Px.
The total amount of people are spending
on good acts as equal to the total
amount agents are getting by
selling all the good acts.
So since everybody's
spending all their money,
that must mean the rest of their money
collectively is just all their money
they're getting from selling good.
Why they must be spending it all
collectively on buying good. Why?
Okay. So that means the next
equation automatically has
to hold because everybody
spent all his money.
So therefore all the money collectively
that was spent on good x equals to the
what's purchased of good acts. Because
supply equals demand for what? X so good.
Why?
It has to be that all the people,
the income of their
getting on spending good,
why all of that was spent on buying.
Why collectively, not any person,
each person and you know,
selling why and buying x or something.
But collectively all the money we've
just to do spent on why I had to go to
buying. Why. So therefore the
why market is clearing too.
So once you've cleared
all the other markets,
you know that the last
market has to clear. So, um,
without loss of generality,
don't worry about last market.
Okay?
Okay. So that reduced it to five equations
and five unknowns. So that helped.
We got rid of one equation and
we got rid of one on known.
So we got rid of the
top equation let's say,
and the F and p x where we got rid of,
you know, one of those two equations.
The market clearing
equations doesn't matter.
As long as we can do all the others and
we one of the prices, we can fix it one.
So then the next step was,
um,
since we can fix p y let's say at one,
why is it was fixed p y at one,
this becomes a much simpler equation.
This now I can replace with one,
and this I can replace with one.
We already know
what the price is of,
of why it's one. Okay.
But now things get very,
very simple because you have a hundred
over minus x over px equals one.
So I just write that again.
A hundred minus px over PA,
a hundred minus x over px equals one.
So I bring the Px to the other side,
and I have a hundred minus x equals one X.
Say,
okay.
Or to put it in another way equals a px.
Another way of writing that is x,
say equals a hundred minus pex.
Okay? And then from this
bottom equation, I've got 30
minus PX,
30 minus X, B, sorry, this was equation.
These are A's. And this was
B. I forgot the s superscript.
So 30 minus X,
B over t x has to eat
well.
Um,
well the margin utility is one, and
the price is one. So that equals one.
So I just have 30 minus XB equals px.
Or in other words,
I have xb just writing this,
bring it to the other
side equals 30 minus x.
Okay, so that, that's the, okay. So
you'll look at the demands of all,
this is what wall Ross did. He said,
forget about all these equations.
Just look at demand and see more
demand. Equal supplies. So here,
given the price px and P why we know
without loss of generality, pis one,
so given Px,
this is how much a is going to demand of x
and given px.
This is how much bs going to demand.
And we know and I call
Librium by that top equation,
that plus that has to equal 84.
So now I can solve it.
So I know that a hundred
minus p well I'm not gonna,
I'm just going to solve it quickly.
So it's 130
minus two px equals 84.
Once you realize that,
um,
46 two px equals 46,
why is it p x equals 23.
Okay.
And once you have px equals 23,
then you can figure out what x a is.
Um, cause 30 minus a hundred
minus x say has to be px.
So that implies x.
Say
he's 23 and it implies that x B is a s
no,
a is 77, right? A hundred minus 20. Oh,
where is x? Say X, say as a
hundred minus px. So px is 23,
x say has to be 77. And implies
that eggs, Xb, I can do eggs,
beef from over here, or 30 minus
Px is seven. And sure enough,
77 plus seven really do equal 84.
So we've cleared the top market and now
we don't have to worry about the other
market.
We can figure out what X B is.
How do we figure out what x B is
when we go into this budget set,
if he's going to add a price of 23 is
going to consume a 77 that's going to cost
a bunch of money and this is how much
income he has. And we subtract it off.
And P is one, we can figure out what Y is.
Okay? So we could figure out from this,
um,
eggs be n Y A and why B?
And we know that that's going to clear
the market. So we solved the problem.
Okay.
But we can do this on a computer.
MMM.
All right.
So there are any questions how I did this?
I'm going to do it one more time with
this model and then I'm going to do it on
a computer. And, uh,
so th th this is the kind of problem that
hopefully it will be second nature to
you after you do the problem set. It's
a very elementary thing. Of course,
the first time you do it
seems very complicated,
but it's a very mechanical
elementary thing,
but it's gonna give us a lot of insight
into the economy. So any questions? Yes,
I was just wondering what those two
lines said. I think the first word,
assume this says without loss of
generality, that px equals one.
Okay.
Second one.
Except that I took p y this
is p why not PXP y equals one
and the second line, this one says,
okay, so without loss of generality,
p why is one,
so having put p y equal to one here,
I then looked at these equations,
a hundred minus x,
say over px equals one over
p y but I took p y to be one.
So that's one over one, which is
one. And I took this equation,
which is 30 minus xb over
px equals one over p y.
So 30 minus XB over px
equals one over p y.
But that's one of her one,
which is one. So I wrote that.
So this is how I got my two
critical equations. Hey,
these two equations here,
this and that went down to this and then
I just rewrote this one is x say is a
hundred minus px and this one you
can write as Xb is 30 minus px.
So 100 minus Px,
30 minus px.
And then I add an x eight XP and I got
130 minus two px equals 84 and I got px.
Yup. So we can set any number, any number.
Yes. You'll just multiply the
prices. If you said p y to be too,
you'd gotten px to be 46
and you get the same answer
relative.
So the only thing that
matters is relative prices.
So this is what vol Ross pointed out.
If you know you change dollars to cents,
you're going to change.
You're going to multiply every price
by a hundred but the relative price of
oranges and tomatoes is going
to be the same as it was before.
So the theory only
produces relative prices.
Any other questions or someone else
raising their hand? Nope. All right,
let's just do it one more time.
So you see,
you get the hang of this and then we're
going to talk about why the market's so
good and we're going to see things are
getting a little bit more complicated.
Okay? So let's do this one.
This one is going to work.
Oh,
so I wasn't very clever here.
Uh Huh.
Oh maybe I couldn't be clever.
More clever. Okay. Okay.
So how do we do this one? Well, we
have to write down all the equations.
So what are they going to
be? They're going to be the
same as before. X a plus X,
B equals e,
a x plus e,
bx pay that supply and demand.
But this is just two
plus one equals three.
And over here we have, it's not
a and B anymore. It's C and D,
I guess I called them c and d.
Okay. And now we have
for, for the second one,
we have x at y c plus Y,
d e equals e c.
Why listen downwind of c of d of y
equals one plus two equals three,
right? So that's supply and demand.
Then we have to do the budget sats.
They're going to be simple p x times x,
c Plus p y times y c has to equal
p x times two plus p y times one,
right?
And then budget set for D is p x times x,
d plus p.
Why things?
Why d equals p x times
one plus p y times two.
Okay? And finally we have
to do the marginal business.
So what's the marginal business?
So somebody tell me this.
So we need the margin utility
of a a,
okay.
Over the price of x.
What's that?
What's the margin utility of x to Mr a
three over four. What?
Okay, that's what you said.
Three or four acts exactly divided by Px.
Okay?
So how did I do that? I took the
derivative of three quarters times.
Log Axis is the only
thing you have to know.
All the derivative log acts is one over
x, okay? And that's going to equal to,
um,
the margin utility of x a y a with respect
to why over p y and that's equal to
what?
One of our four,
hold on,
we'll have a for why we're here.
Yes, my A's are sees. Thank you.
I'm glad you pointed that out. Um,
thanks. So you know, it's embarrassing
to make all these mistakes,
but you'll find in 30 years you'll
start making mistakes too. Anyway,
so here we go. So, um, okay,
so that's that equation.
And then we have to do the same thing
for y and I should have been more clever
and left more room, but
I didn't. But anyway,
the last equation is going to be margin.
Yeah. So what is the last equation?
Let's just,
okay.
Margin utility of d a x
divided by p x equals what?
Okay.
Two thirds times one
override divided by px equals
right.
Equals what? Margin until equals.
I'm not going to write out margin.
Utility of y divided by p.
Why is what?
Why d
okay.
Divided by p y. Okay, so
those are the equations.
So now we're going to
put these on a computer,
but we can solve these by hand again and
we're going to see it's very useful to
be able to do this
almost.
Okay? So let's, uh, okay, so what,
there's another trick to doing this.
So the trick is, okay, we can
trake p one of them to be won,
whichever we want to do.
Take p y to be one or Px to be one.
So take p x equal one.
Here you see things are a
little bit more symmetric there.
There was the special why that
had constant margin utility.
Just like in our football
tickets example here,
there's nothing that has constant margin.
Utility x and y are much more symmetric.
So this move to more symmetry without
the special acts is very important.
And the guy who first did that was
actually Irving Fisher at Yale.
You're gonna hear a lot about very soon.
So it's a little bit more complicated
this time. So what is the, uh,
okay, so here's the critical
equation. This one, let's say,
okay, so now I'm going
to solve this. Okay?
So I just, so how can I do this? I want,
I want to do the same trick
is before I now want to solve.
So let's take p to be one like
I did before, apy to be one.
Okay? So let's just solve
this equation. Solve for x. So
how can we,
it's not gonna be so easy to do this.
MMM.
Okay. So now there's a tremendous
trick here. What does this say?
If I rewrite this, it says, yes,
mmm,
I can bring the x down here
and I get Px Times X. Okay?
And I can bring the white down
here and I get p y times y.
So it says that the amount you spend on
x relative to three quarters is equal to
the amount. This is,
by the way, Mister, uh,
see the amounts see spends on x relative
to three quarters is equal to the
amount he spends on why?
Relative to one quarter. Okay?
But the total spending on x and
y has gotta be all his income.
So basically it says that he spends
three quarters was income on x and one
quarter on why? That's
the crucial insight. Okay.
So that you can solve these logarithmic
examples very easily by that trick.
Okay? So it's evident, evident
from margin utility equation
that C,
we'll spend
three quarters of his income
on x and D we'll spend
two thirds of her income
on x by the same argument. She's going
to have two thirds, you know, look,
I can bring XD down and she's gonna
spend her spending on x relative to two
thirds is equal to her spending
on why relative to one third,
but she's spending all her income
on x and y. So clearly, you know,
two thirds of it is being spent on
x and one third of it on why. Okay.
So that property of the
log utilities is no eggs,
no accident. They were invented
for exactly that purpose.
So it was a story you probably heard, but
there is a famous, uh, I'm from Illinois.
There was a famous, uh,
Senator Douglas from Illinois,
been several Douglas's from Illinois.
Um, one of them debate in Lincoln.
But anyway,
there's a famous,
maybe it wasn't familiar to me and
there was a famous senator from Lincoln,
was really where I am.
There's a famous senator named Douglas
from Illinois after the civil war.
And he noticed that, you know, farmers,
you labor tended to get two thirds to
three quarters of all the income and
capital the rest.
So he said,
what kind of utility function would make
me always spend the same fraction of
wine money on a particular good.
And so he went to his,
a college math teacher calm and uh,
asked him if he could invent any utility
function which had the property that
you always spent
a fixed proportion of
your money on each good.
And so Cobb invented the Cobb Douglas
Utility function. And this is where it is,
is just the sum of a logs.
Okay.
So it's called Cobb Douglas Utility.
So it has that property,
this property that each
person who is Cobb, Doug,
US utility spends a fixed proportion
of her money on each of the goods,
a different proportion
on each of the goods.
And different people have
different proportions,
but any single person is going to
always spend a given proportion.
Three quarters on acts one quarter on
why two thirds on x one quarter and why?
And because of that,
it's very easy to solve for equilibrium.
So we go x say is going to be
three quarters. What is her income?
Her income is px times
two plus p y times one.
Okay.
Okay. And, and, and her, okay.
So that's her income has to be that
she's going to send three quarters for
income annex.
So I could write essays
that and meanwhile eggs.
So this is c and XD is going to be,
he's,
she's spending two thirds of her income on
x
and um,
one third on why.
So her spouse, her endowments are
one unit of x and two units of y.
So this is her income px
times one plus p y times too.
And so she's spending
two thirds of it on x.
So therefore px times XD, that's
the amount of money she spends on x.
That's what she spends. An axe
has to be that. So XD is that,
and if I add these two, okay, I
have to get, when I add them up,
I have to get two plus one equals three.
Okay.
So I can just now solve this.
Okay,
well I can do a trick and pick one
of my either p extra p y to be one.
So either one, I keep going back and
forth. It doesn't make any difference.
Let's try p why is one can take
that to be one and I can solve it.
So this is just three quarters
times p x times two plus one
probably. Anyway, it doesn't
matter. It divided by Px.
Um,
okay.
And then the other one is two thirds px
times one plus two eight divided by Px.
So I can add those. Okay. And it has to
equal when I add those and equals three.
So I know that three Px,
if I multiply through by Px,
I get three px equals three halves.
Hopefully I did this right.
Three ass x,
this will be very
embarrassing if I didn't.
Three FPX plus three
quarters plus two thirds px,
um,
plus four thirds equals three px.
Oh,
is this right?
So who can do this in their heads? Three
halves. Px from that is three halves.
Px. So three halves. Wine is two thirds.
Three halves is nine.
Six minus four.
Six is five. Six it looks
like five, six px. Hey,
does anyone believe that if
I do this in terms of a six,
that's nine sixth,
nine over six and that's a four over six.
That's 13 over six and that's 18 over six.
So it's five over six px that looks right
and three quarters plus four thirds.
If I go to twelves,
that's a nine.
12 and 16.
12 is 25 twelves
so this looks like, um, five has,
okay, so px. Sorry.
So that means px equals five halves.
Okay,
so there I've got the answer.
Okay.
Does that look right to you?
Is this clear? What I did here?
I just took for this trick,
all I did was I solve for,
okay, so let's just repeat what
I did. Just like over there.
I reduced it to simultaneous equations
in a mechanical way, in a very simple,
straightforward mechanical way,
which the first time you see it looks
very complicated. But uh, it's, you know,
it's very simple.
In fact after you've done it once and
then it allows you to take these very
complicated models and say
something concrete. So I've
got all the peoples there,
their welfare functions
and their endowments.
So I say an equilibrium was what has
to happen. Whatever they decide to eat.
C And d, what he eats plus what
she eats has to be the endowment.
The total endowment is three. So the
total consumption of access to be three,
the total consumption of y between when
he eats and what she eats also has to be
three. Okay. Now each of them is
going to spend all their money.
He's going to spend all his money,
she's going to spend all her money
because it's carb Douglas because it's
logarithmic and you do this margin
utility stuff. You find out,
and this was the only trick. So this
is a non obvious trek, you know,
which some senator and a uh,
a professional mathematician
had to invent Cobb dog.
This is designed so that you can say
right away with those utility functions,
d is clearly going to spend two thirds
of her money buying x and C is going to
spend three quarters of his money buying
x as just obvious from the first order
conditions from this margin utility.
They're called first door to conditions
from this equating margin utilities.
That was the crucial
trick. Okay, so that's one.
So that's a trick that you have to
internalize and you know from now on,
that's all you have to know that sees
going to spend three quarters of his money
on x one quarter of his money on why and
going to spend two thirds of her money
on acts and one third on y, but supply
to equal demand. So what is, see,
what is he actually buying?
Here's his total money he gets,
he has two units of x and one unit of y.
So he's selling his units of acts at the
price px and engineers of why the price
p y and you spending three
quarters of an annex,
so how much excess he actually buying.
This is the amount of money he spending
on x divided by the price of Px.
That's how much money he buys of ex.
She d she's going to spend,
here's her income,
which is not quite the same as his cause.
Their endowments different.
That's her income.
She spends two thirds of it on x,
so the amount of x she wants to buy is
the amount of money she spends on it
divided by the price.
That's how much she wants to buy.
Now I just have to add x c plus XD.
It's very hard for me to do at
the board and you to follow there,
but of course if you'll stare at the
page for a minute, it's you know,
at home it will be very simple to follow.
I do another, I do vall Ross's trick.
I said I can always take PYP to be
one. Okay. If I take p to be one,
I'm going to get this income is px two
times one times one, which is just one.
So three quarters of this divided by Px,
that's what he's buying.
She's buying two thirds of her income,
which is px times one plus one times two,
which is plus two divided by p access.
What she's buying.
And I just add this to this
and do a little Algebra, okay?
So I just add and do a little
Algebra and lo and behold,
px is equal to five halves. So I happened
to remember that's the right number.
So I actually did this right? So
px is equal to five halves, okay?
And we solved the whole problem.
So of Px is equal to five halves.
How much is she actually,
um,
how much is she actually buying of x?
Well,
I could always plug this back in.
Plug in Px is equal to five halves and
find out that's five plus one is six.
You know, times three quarters,
divide by five halves.
That would tell me how much x
she see she was buying. Okay?
So and I could plug in five halves
for Pex and I'd get how much XD,
how much Dee was buying a vax and I could
also plug px equal to five halves and
p y equal to one and find out
what they were doing of good d.
Okay.
So you can solve it by hand very easily.
But let's just solve it by computer
instead unless there's a question. Huh?
I stopped it. Any questions
about what I did here? Yes.
Okay. Well now we haven't gotten
here yet. Now we're going to we,
so I'm obviously not,
I run over a little bit so I'm going
to finish the class by doing this,
repeating this calculation on a computer
just by pressing a button and you'll
see what the answer is. Okay. Uh,
but then we have to examine the question.
Have we really maximized utility here?
And to give away the punchline
that utility was very special.
It was constant margin utility
of one and a particular good y.
That's what made this example is almost
identical to the football ticket example.
The final equilibrium's going to
maximize the sum of utilities here.
This equilibrium is not going to
maximize the sum of utilities.
There's no reason it should
And so you need a different definition
of why the free market is such a good
thing.
So economists made a tremendous mistake.
They thought that the original criteria
and for a good market is you maximize
the sum of utilities. That's not even
true in an example like this one.
So we need a different definition,
which we call parade. Oh, efficiency.
That that illustrates
why the market's good,
but if they made an economy will mistake
once stands to reason they could make a
mistake another time. So there's something
special. Even about this example,
when we put in financial variables,
I'm going to argue you shouldn't expect
to get the optimal outcome all the time,
but that will be next class.
Yes,
like arithmetic.
Is there any reasons you choose to assume?
Yeah,
no. There's no reason to pick px or p
y to be one, whichever one you want.
You can choose to be one,
and I keep going.
I can never make up my mind
which one to do. So yeah,
just whatever works out this one,
it clearly worked out
arithmetically easy to take.
P Y go to one because the marginal utility
of why it was one and that canceled
everything out here.
I could have taken either one price
to be one and wouldn't have helped.
So I picked p why did we want again?
Okay,
so let's just in the last five minutes,
let's just soft show how to
solve this by computer. Um,
and so this is something you also are
going to be able to do. And you know,
it sounds like, oh, there's so many
complicated things. Is this new equations,
you know, it's, you do
this for the problem set,
it will after you've done
it once for the problem.
So you may have a little trouble with
the problem set, the TA's will help you,
but after you do at once,
this will be very simple.
Now doing a bike computer is also
very simple and it's going to sound
complicated, but you know,
as all you young people, no,
if any old guy can figure
out how to work a computer,
you can do it vastly quicker. So let's
just take the second example here.
Okay. And, and we have five minutes left.
That's all it will take. So this is an XL.
Now Xcel is this program that's
made zillions of dollars.
The inventor of XL, by the way, um,
was the inventor of Lotus. Uh,
oh, what was the guy's name?
Um, his sister was in my class at
Yale. He was two ahead of me. Go,
go, go. Uh, not Gabor,
Mitch, Mitch, Mitch, Gabor,
something like that was his name.
Anyway,
she was in my class and he was two years
ahead of me and he invented this thing
called Lotus, which made
a lot of money. And uh,
then it got bought out by a few people
and then Xcel just basically, you know,
copied the entire thing and a Microsoft
and made a fortune and had to pay him
off for plagiarizing the thing. But
anyway, it's, it's basically Mitch.
Gabor was the inventor and
a Yale undergraduate. Okay.
Two years ahead of me.
So he made, you know, he's a billionaire
now, so let's just solve the problem.
Let's do the second one says,
I may not have time for the first one.
So what did I do? I said let's write down
the exogenous variables first. Sorry,
let's go up.
Okay,
so the exogenous variables are the
endowment of x of the two goods a and B.
That's two and one. Okay. And I've,
I've bee is wanting to now what
are the variables? Px, p y x,
a y a XP and my be, we don't know what
those are. So I've plugged in, you know,
Px and p y I'll gas. Both of them are
one, which is obviously going to be wrong.
And I'll guess that people just
end up with their endowments,
which is obviously not right.
Okay. So then I look at the
budget set. So the, okay,
so those are my guesses for the,
these are the endogenous variables
and wild guesses about the solution.
Now what are the equations where we wrote
them down? There's the budget set of a,
so that's just the budget set of a,
so how do you write these equations down?
Okay. You simply name the, it's up here.
If you haven't used excel before,
up here,
you write down the
letter C B 35 that's px.
So be 35 times,
be 31 that's P X is be
35 times endowment X.
Say that's the, that's the
income I wrote the income first,
that's the income a has minus how much
she spends or he spends be 35 times 37 B
35 remembers the price of XP.
37 is how much a he buys. Okay?
So that's just the budget sense.
So for each of these equations,
the margin utility,
I just did the same thing.
Remember the three quarters over px
times x and w you know equals one quarter
times p y times y.
So this should be equal to zero.
All these equations are I instead of
saying this equals that I subtract the
right hand side from the left hand side.
So you want all these
equations to be equal to zero.
I just wrote down the sick six equations.
Okay?
And so XL now tells me, you
know, the, of course the budget,
the budget's set is going to be satisfied
automatically because people are
consuming their endowments
and the budget's set of bees
automatically satisfied.
Cause I've just had them
choosing their endowments.
And markets are going to clear of course,
cause everybody's choosing their
endowments but they're not optimizing.
So the first order this a margin
utility stuff is all screwed up.
So what do I do on the right
for every error in the equation,
I square it so I've squared all the
errors. Okay? So these are my equations.
I need to satisfy one, two, four, five,
six equations, one, two, three, four,
five, six and I some the squares. Okay.
So if I make the sum of the squares zero,
each of those has to be zero.
So Xcel now can minimize
the sum of squared errors.
Xcel is going to search over
all indogenous variables,
px through y B to find the things that
makes this number of smallest possible.
Once this number becomes zero means
all the ones above it have to be zero
because they're all squared numbers.
Adding up to that.
And so I will found a solution.
So you see that all you have to do,
if you've done this before, of course
it's obvious. If you haven't, you know,
it's just so simple to write the equation,
supplying demands. I just mean the box,
you know, be, you know,
I'll be 32. That's just uh,
you know,
that's the endowment of why a plus the
endowment of a y B equals the consumption
of, of a a plus the consumption
of me. That's the difference.
We want to make. Zero,
okay, so here, here's how you solve
it. There's a thing called solver.
So you go to tools and you hit
solver and now solve, says,
okay, you want to take a target
cell? I cheated. I already
knew what it was. See 47.
So it's the target cell. I hit
minimize. So I want to minimize that.
And now what cells do I change?
Well,
I have to tell excel what the search over.
So now Xcel,
what are the, what are the
cells? I could say PXP you know,
all the indigenous variables, but I
know I can fix px. To be one. Okay.
So I'm going to forget that one. And
I'm going to say just these five, right?
I don't need all six of them. Just five
cause I can always take px to be one.
Okay? So active, the solver now knows
it wants to minimize this number,
which is the air, the squared errors of
all the equations I want to hold equal.
It's going to minimize that by
searching over all those numbers.
It's not very smart
about searching for it.
And sometimes it never finds an answer.
We know there always is an answer. And uh,
so how do you solve it? You just hit
Sov and it's going to search and do it.
And what should the answer be?
If I fix px to be one.
Okay. Remember the answer was when p why
is one extra is out to be five halves.
If I fix px to be one,
what should be why B?
The solution we got before was
px equals five halves and p.
Why is one now I'm going to fix px
to be one. So what should, why B
x was five halves times.
Why?
So why should be 0.4 so
if this solves right,
we should get y p y to be point for us,
I just did Saul and Voila,
I get Pete.
Why to before I find x ne is
1.8 I find all the numbers.
It's just solve it just
like that instantly. Okay.
So you can see how useful it's going to
be to use a solver and do these problems
can change. Of course, if
I change the endowments,
I'll get a different answer.
And if I
increase the endow, yes it
does. And that's very important.
If I double everybody's endowment,
if I end up with one endowment
that's going to change things around.
If I double everybody's endowment,
it won't change anything. Yeah.